dance now has nine points including the
last seventh of the Cavaliers the
tropics it from 30 coming been in the
heat rotation since opening night of his
rookie you were a great example there
are three different white jerseys and
he's the one that keeps the play alive
for Maya and Silva on the floor for
Erickson bolts receipt enjoy a 16 point
lead
Kelly Oh along with hero really a nice
trio in terms of scoring and assisting
and just getting everyone else in time
now the Robinson triples set up by the
drugget steal three or four from
downtown love has the last nine Cavalier
points that's Robins hit the rattles
down another triple that the Cavaliers
can't cover all the positions on the
floor Robinson has 15 tweets by the room
if the quarter they find him and he does
his thing
rattle stand on another truffle jus
minutes left in the head
beat up 20 there's Robinson again
[Applause]
35 seconds left second quarter it's hero
back for banner
Selena shoot Duncan will
[Applause]